Hallo ihr Lieben, heute gibt's eine Raffaello-Erdbeertorte!
"Warum?" fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich (oder auch nicht!)
Ich hab euch auf Instagram gefragt, was ich mit all meinen Raffaellos machen soll.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit so einiges an Besuch bekommen, immer mal wieder  und mir wurde
immer Raffaello mitgebracht weil ich mag Raffaello auch total gern  und genieße das immer total!
Aber jetzt habe ich so viele übrig, dass ich dachte: "Okay die verarbeite ich jetzt in einer Torte!"
bzw. nehmen wir sie als Inspiration für eine Erdbeer-Raffaello Torte.
Und wir starten jetzt auch erstmal mit der Creme. Den Boden habe ich nämlich vorgebacken,
dazu sage ich euch nachher noch was. Und für die Creme habe ich jetzt hier meine
Küchenmaschine denn ich mache jetzt die Creme, die ich am liebsten habe.
Ich nehme Mascarpone, Frischkäse und Sahne und schlag' das alles in einer Schüssel.
Das funktioniert aber nur, wenn alle Zutaten kalt sind,  die kommen ganz frisch aus dem Kühlschrank.
(H: Und die Rührschüssel!)
Sehr gut! Und die Rührschüssel ist auch kalt!
Gerade jetzt im Sommer Rührschüssel, Schneebesenaufsatz für 5min in den Kühlschrank
stellen und dann habt ihr gar keine Probleme.
(H: Oder kaltes Wasser drauf!)
Oder mit kaltem Wasser abspülen und trocknen.
Hamza, richtig gut! Respekt!
(H: Ich hab vom Meister  gelernt!)
Die Bestandteile waren jetzt sehr fest - also Mascarpone und Frischkäse - und das Ganze lockern
wir jetzt durch Sahne auf. Und alles in allem ist das eine Creme, die ich am Ende
zum Befüllen benutze, zum äußeren Bestreichen und für die Deko, für die Häubchen oben drauf,
deswegen liebe ich diese Creme! Und gerade im Sommer wenn es schnell gehen muss
und man hier auch nicht so lange in der Küche stehen will, ist sie einfach perfekt!
Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt gebe ich auch schon mit dazu und Sahnefest
lasse ich erst nach ½min ungefähr einrieseln.
Und zack, ist die Creme fertig! Wie schnell das ging, also ruckzuck! Und ich habe jetzt hier Erdbeeren,
da hab ich mir die schönsten beiseite gelegt für die Deko später.
und den Rest habe ich klein geschnitten.  Und mein  Biskuitboden, das ist ein Grundrezept,
das kennt ihr schon. Das verlinke ich euch in die Infobox und ich schreibe euch auch ganz genau
die Mengenangaben, die ich verwendet habe, denn wir brauchen für dieses Rezept nur 2 Böden.
Und deshalb werde ich meinen Biskuitboden - der ist komplett abgekühlt -
jetzt einmal in der Hälfte durchteilen. Und dann können wir schon anfangen  mit dem Schichten.
So, jetzt werde ich noch die Creme ein bisschen aufpimpen, ich habe mir aber vorab ein Viertel
erstmal zur Seite getan,  das brauche ich später noch für die Deko. Und den Rest, da werde ich jetzt
Kokosraspeln dazugeben und einfach mit dem Teigschaber einrühren.
Ihr nehmt euch jetzt einen Tortenring zur Hilfe und bestreicht schon mal
nur ein bisschen die Oberfläche des ersten Bodens.
Das brauchen wir damit die Erdbeeren jetzt  so ein bisschen dran haften bleiben.
Und dann kommt auf jeden Fall noch mehr Creme dazu.
Und ich mache das jetzt auch so, dass die Erdbeeren bei mir nur auf den ersten Boden kommen
weil ich mir das im Anschnitt auch sehr schön vorstelle,
wenn dann der Boden ist, Erdbeeren und dann oben nur noch weiße Schichten.
So, in die obere Schicht gebe ich jetzt noch ein paar versteckte halbierte Raffaellos,
damit man sich dann beim Anschnitt auch richtig freut.
So, jetzt ist ja oben auch alles glatt verstrichen und da wir jetzt eine sehr feste Creme haben,
haben wir jetzt gerade noch keine Kühlzeit. Das heißt ich kann den Backrahmen, also den Tortenring,
mit meinem Backformlöser direkt einmal entfernen und dann die Seiten auch noch mit Creme bestreichen.
So ihr Süßen! Nachdem ihr dann die Torte rundherum nochmal bestrichen habt,
einmal komplett mit Kokosraspeln umhüllen. Und ich find' die sieht so schon irgendwie ganz cool aus,
minimalistisch...einfach 'ne Kokos-Bombe!
Aber wir müssen jetzt natürlich noch mit Erdbeeren und Raffaello dekorieren weil das einfach hübsch ist!
Das sieht einfach hübsch aus. So und wir machen jetzt folgendes: Ihr müsst euch jetzt
einen kleinen Löffel nehmen, denn unsere Sahnehäubchen - also die Creme,
die wir uns jetzt hier am Anfang beiseite gelegt haben - die habe ich in einen Spritzbeutel gefüllt
mit Sterntülle vorne dran.
Die Sahne hält nicht auf den Kokosraspeln. Deshalb macht einfach folgendes:
Ihr schiebt so ein bisschen - also da wo ihr die Tupfer platzieren möchtet -
schiebt ihr die Kokosraspeln beiseite und dann dekoriert ihr ganz einfach.
Einfach der Fantasie freien Lauf lassen!
Ta-daa, fertig ist die Erdbeere-Raffaello-Torte, ich finde die so so hübsch!
Und geschmacklich ist sie natürlich auch mega, denn ich durfte sie schon probieren.
Aber auf Instagram machen wir immer noch zusätzlich den Taste Test passend zum Video.
Also wenn ihr uns auf Instagram noch nicht folgt, dann holt das jetzt ganz schnell nach!
Schreibe ich euch auch hier unten in die Videobeschreibung
und was ich euch noch dazuschreibe, sind natürlich die ganz genauen Mengenangaben.
Und dann könnt ihr ja ab zu Kaufland und dann einfach mal das Ganze einkaufen und nachmachen!
Und dann freue ich mich natürlich über Fotos! Postet sie auch gerne auf Instagram, dann gucke ich mir sie an.
Und jetzt wünsche ich euch einfach nur noch ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen
dieser wunder-wunderschönen Torte!
Und wir sehen uns dann bei meinem nächsten Rezeptvideo oder einem Vlog
oder auf meinem neuen Format: Kikis Kitchen Hacks!
Falls ihr's noch nicht kennt: das Video werde ich euch auch am Ende nochmal verlinken!
Also bis dann! Tschüss, eure Kiki!